what you can feel is that they are why is this
so challenging right now okay these people really
knew the person they lost so they get a
chance to uh you know draw from something real
from there and you could feel that pain uh
in here and i guess that's the thing that was
latching onto so much what is going on
there citizens of the reject nation the
trailer that we all expected to come out has
actually come out black panther to wakanda
forever john how are you feeling
you're excited as a black man i am very
of course you are well as a latino man i'm very
excited to see some culture represented here too
absolutely andrew as a white man how are you are
you excited to see every k ross returning here
very excited but now i'm feeling emotional just
of course of course just we already know what i'm
feeling emotional about but uh excited uh for
uh what we're about to see as well i imagine
it's kind of strange because you're gonna you've
got a shoehold trailer that i'm imagining a very
different trailer here so guys leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated you could
also subscribe and click that notification
bell but enough chit chat uh let's see what
ryan coogler and team has in store for uh
something that i imagine was a massive task
right off the bat
good friends we've lost
along the way
in this great future you can't forget yourself
that little submariner
and here we go
wow
the makeup looks
and phenomenal entire family is
gone have i not given everything
okay let's go
oh
that was so swelling yeah oh my god that
was so oh wow i was like i i had a feeling
this would be a more serious trailer but i was
like that was very you could feel the grievance
throughout that whole trailer and yeah and
the pain that's the [__] [__] oh god
rest in peace chadwick bozeman yeah oh
what is this [__] trailer god damn it
oh man it needs to okay we need to get
focused people well that's the thing
i flashed back because you know it's like we've
seen the tony stark mural all over the mcu since
the character but it hits you totally different to
see the mural of t'challa and to see that image of
chadwick like like any time that shows up here
from now on is i feel like it's gonna tug your
heart string i mean you have to be like extra
sensitive with handling you know this material
and you could they said that you would feel the
presence of chadwick boseman throughout and it
seems like what they're really capturing here is
the loss of t'challa through every character like
so much of that harrowing painstaking quality
is here it's like yeah you mean you got all the
cool marvel stuff of course you know like that's
normally what you do when you watch the marvel
trailers you're like oh there's namor look at
the culture being exposed like there's stuff
i can already pick up on in terms of plot uh
that it looks like they they they pull neymar
out right like he's in these in whatever that tank
is of the water something yeah yeah it looks like
whatever that military operation is yeah and then
it's gonna lead to a war with the atlanteans and
uh the wakandans and ramon angela bassett holy
cow she looks so powerful in this movie he looks
so powerful oh yeah everyone does you know despite
whatever opinion differences you have with leticia
rightly she looks freaking amazing in this movie
too yeah but i mean andrew how are you man um
again i think uh how i described how i was gonna
be earlier just really emotional i think john just
put it best like it's one thing when you see the
mural of a character that just died as a character
but when you see something you know the actor
actually passed away just it hits you differently
and um like you guys were just mentioning earlier
i'm glad that they're paying respect you know you
feel you do feel the presence of chadwick but it's
done in a very respectful way and it actually is
integral to the plot uh so i'm glad that they're
they're doing that and then obviously you know we
get to see some really cool stuff with neymar i
think we got a glimpse too of uh riri williams oh
we definitely did yeah and then uh we got that
sick shot of uh i'm assuming that shuri in the
black panther suit at the end that was really
cool as well yeah if you know anything about
riri williams i mean this is such a cool character
that brian michael bendis came up with that he was
they were going to be filming a uh tv show in
chicago and uh that show got scrapped but he
came up with the idea for this character and she's
just on a different level of intelligence and it's
gonna be really fascinating how they're going
to uh and obviously her character is also known
as iron heart uh it's going to be interesting
it's going to be interesting to see how they uh
integrated her into the mcu without tony stark
because that was a very big thing in the comic
book so i'm very curious to see how ryan coogler
introduces her in this film but i really like uh
just a little glimpse of what we have seen so far
of her and i like that we're already gonna see a
little bit of the origin story of namor that looks
really interesting as well excuse me guys holy
yeah no this is the rare occasion where like it
is a cultural moment like the first black panther
was for its own reasons and this one is something
that i think yeah is like super touching and it's
like we all lost a little something i mean for
everybody involved who was close to chadwick
boseman obviously it is much greater but yeah
like this is one of those movies that this is
gonna be an emotional experience and a visceral
experience and i i love the way the film styles
complement that feeling because so much of the
early parts it is just like ryan coogler up in the
emotions which he is so good at but then you have
this other stuff that looks like a nolan thriller
or stuff that looks like avatar 300 like and all
those movies aim for some level of like emotional
harrowing harrowing emotional you know
expression to some degree so glad you
yeah it was just so epic and sweeping
and just so beautiful to beholden and
there's something that's weirdly like uh
cathartic about it i need to stop right now
um the one we have so many things in this office
and the one thing we don't have are [__] tissues
for some reason yeah yeah okay okay um all right
uh yeah i just i need to take that in i i wasn't
expecting to be so so moved you know it was more
like i'm curious to see how they're gonna do this
this looks like this could
be one of the most powerful
moving experiences from from marvel and and
it's it's like they had to work with such a
something so delicate so sensitive and you
could feel like there's something that felt
that registered is so authentic in the in the mood
of this trailer you know and and it seemed like i
guess what i was picking up on what's so effective
about the loss here is that these actors seem like
they they're the ones who really need like 99 of
us didn't know chadwick boseman and they're the
ones who really knew chadwick bozeman and
when you get the sense of this trailer is
excuse me
i'm gonna get through this i promise this is so
awkward i've never been between
two male friends before crying
what you can feel is that they are why is this
so challenging right now okay let's breathe
just i feel like i'm making this about
like me and i don't make it about me um
the reason it's so challenging is because the
reason it's so cathartic is because you know like
from from acting experiences you know sometimes
people have the thing of like you draw from pain
or like real life things or you know you just
dropped to the minds of the characters and these
people really knew the person they lost so they
get a chance to uh you know draw from something
real from there and you could feel that pain uh
in here and i guess that's the thing that was
latching on to so much because you can feel it
in every face and in how the camera takes it all
like it's everybody and the song choices as
well yeah that was uh that was yeah you know
it's the one thing that like when you cry
watching something but when you're like
just trying to talk about it yeah yeah i can tell
you this i mean this is an obvious statement i'm
going to be bringing a whole tissue box when
i see this film [__] [__] um alrighty
well hey john wesh close this out man guys thank
you for joining us uh hey leave a like leave a
comment on what we want to know your thoughts as
well were you as you know affected and moved as
we were and uh hey keep an eye out we're gonna
talk about as well the other announcements from
phase five four and five and beyond so thank
you for joining us and uh we'll see you soon